le corps de sapeurs pompiers réunionnais
n'a pas dérogé à la règle en ce 14
juillet 2016
des hommes du feu étaient présents
traditionnel défilé parmi ses troupes
les jeunes sapeurs pompiers également
mise à l'honneur sur le barachois lui
pour le défilé du 14 juillet nous avons
mobilisé l'ensemble des troupes
représentative glisse 10 notamment une
section de départementale 2 sympa
pompiers la formation initiale il
s'accomplit jeunes sont complets qui
viennent de rentrer une section de
jeunes sapeurs pompiers qui est en
formation également ainsi que une
section spécialisée qui est le délit h
et les bac pro qui est une section de
l'école pas tous heureusement fin du
lycée patu des heureusement pour un
total de 134 défilant en plus des des
troupes à pied
nous avons donc un groupe autorisée qui
va défiler composé de huit véhicules
qu'ils soient sous le commandement du
capitaine au chef du csp de sanogo des
sapeurs-pompiers fier de faire partie de
ce défilé et des sapeurs-pompiers
applaudi lors de leur passage des hommes
mais également des véhicules qui
impressionne toujours des troupes
présentes à la réunion mais également
des troupes présentes sur les champs
elysées une vingtaine d'hommes du sdiss
réunion a eu l'honneur de participer à
la parade nationale devant le chef de
l'état
puisque il y as depuis maintenant sept
huit ans un bataillon france qui est
créé chaque année au niveau national
pour représenter les pompiers civils
lors du défilé du 14 juillet de cette
année c'est donc tout l'outre-mer qui a
été chargé de représenter l'île de la
réunion qui a été chargé de piloter
cette affaire et donc il y aura 25
servons empire réunionnais sur les 80
qui vont défiler le représentant du
département cyrille melchior étaient
présents pour cet événement patriotique
qui met en avant les forces de défense
de la nation
le vice président a voulu rendre hommage
à l'engagement des militaires mais aussi
à nos sapeurs pompiers
maintenant effectivement a toute sa
place à l'occasion de la célébration de
ce 14 juillet c'est une fête nationale
et pour nous c'est l'occasion d' avant
de penser à nos militaires et notamment
réunionnais qui participera à travers
les forces françaises aux différentes
actions
il y en a même qui ont laissé leur vie
dont quelques pas en poudre et leur
rendre hommage à nos militaires et au
masque et bien sûr des réunionnais mais
c'est aussi l'occasion de montrer que le
département n'a rayon même prendre toute
sa place dans les mesures de sécurité
pour notre département justement à
travers par exemple 6 et on a vu défiler
des personnels de justice
on avait du matériel que le département
finance est bien pour nous c'est notre
façon à nous de participer à la
protection civile et à la protection des
biens mais surtout des personnes ici à
la réunion
le défilé du 14 juillet a également été
l'occasion pour le représentant de
l'état de décor et plusieurs militaires
de l'ordre national de la légion
d'honneur